you're not all looting and getting not
telling me what's going on here
yeah i'm just picking stuff up do you
want a shotgun or uh
you should go in the front rahul he
didn't say that yeah you should find the
witch
there it is wait no that's just a dead
person wait that is that
not her no it's not oh hello i'm not
charging
oh charger hey i've been charged very
good
okay i'm old i'm being pummeled he's all
right yeah you're all right you're all
right
just my average friday night you want to
go under this bridge
okay are we making him find the witch
first
he's our leader okay
yeah exactly go through these trees do
you see these trees right here
he oh
hunting rifle oh my god oh my gosh oh
no okay hang on let me throw my pipe
bomb john i'm with you
on accident um maybe maybe like that
kind of situation
maybe that'll work
i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] it up oh my gosh
okay hey buddy hey buddy where's the
defense go inside the house
just oh morning heal me damn it i'm the
cutest
[Applause]
sorry about that click back into the
game you know how it is why there's so
many special zombies so quickly
so this game is just a friggin hoof it
is it
didn't teach me anything about this game
yeah well i thought maybe
i thought you know because you're in
that zombie show on cw so we've maybe
thought you know
we don't have stupid [ __ ] witches
maybe you should but you're into the
crane
are you [ __ ] me you're ready to
fight the horde
well whoa that was loud that was loud
that was loud why was that so loud oh
no oops i summoned the horde
ah who did that john got molotovs
of course it was john how did i know hey
congrats on getting an achievement
thank you i like how it showed all of us
there's a bunch of weapons and stuff in
here just get whatever
is good there's some shotguns
all right all right all right all right
all right all right there's so many
zombies behind you rival
they know who you are i
that small under any circumstances
harrison ford been up in this [ __ ]
there we go things are not going out
yeah
we have a few minutes oh
but do we have a safe room they're
coming they're coming we're not
out no no oh no my god
oh god guys we can't do this we can't
i'm not ready for any of this business
well you were asking a very important
question
you were i missed every one of those
shots good thing i can't remember
now it was like i don't know who would
you rather so would you if you had no
you're not
suck a zombie's dick or um let the
zombie [ __ ] you up the ass
um can you get infected zombie dick in
both situations
okay you're getting a lot i'm not saying
any of the other two so it's the only
way
does zombie dick fall off mid coitus no
but it will
a zombie can only [ __ ] for about a
minute can a zombie come oh
would you get the zombie infection if
you had sex no no he said you won't
it will grant you immunity maybe
probably can't come but you will get hiv
oh yeah secure just for fun green
everywhere yeah it's a boomer yeah
that's a boomer i feel like the word
boomer is particularly funny now that
we're playing this game in 2020
like it said a boomer spat on pizza and
i was like [ __ ] boom is bro
what will they ruin a lot of people yeah
i don't know i feel like
again i feel like i'm gonna eat the eat
the zombie dick i think that
that's the preferable option here um
i would do neither well then you would
die then you're
you're infected
[Laughter]
what's in this big tower over here i bet
there's goodies inside oh it's not
destiny jacob
oh this smokes i've been smoked i've
been smoked and i'm dying uh and i'm
dying
and i'm dying i got him thank you watch
out
oh boy it's it's like having asthma you
know this video game represents me in
real life
asthma is in the mind oh jesus
i got you i got you baby boy i got you
girl you so cute are you single
yes yeah you wanna because you killed my
boyfriend he
[Laughter]
why are they like are they complaining
about avocados or something
yeah they have a low tip
[Laughter]
would you rather okay oh have
uh a butt hole the size of a grapefruit
okay and every time you poop you like
fill the toilet
it just falls out okay bottle the size
of a grape and you have to like you have
to like stand on top of the toilet
because it's so high wait wait my
butthole is the size of a grapefruit is
what you're telling me
it's like this circumference yeah yeah
it's beautiful twisting
yeah do you have a dick shaped like a
can of spam like
is it just is it like a chode basically
yeah
kind of spam's not a chose that's just
very thick
but it's isn't it shows like equal part
length and width
and it has a pull tab on the top of it
anyway as person who doesn't have a dick
i feel like having a cho
dick wouldn't be so bad then you can
like show dick you have a
you have a very specifically shaped what
the [ __ ] yeah that seems like it would
be okay
you don't know you don't know what a
show it is disney actors don't say these
kinds of things
when were you on disneyland
wait it didn't work oh [ __ ] this is how
we die
this is this is it for us what if prince
troyer and ving rhames had a baby
he's dead okay okay okay okay come on
okay we gotta fuel this thing
i'm still stuck on the grapefruit part
great whoa what what oh
i smoked it smoked fall i don't want an
anus that big
roll please help you'll write that oh
thank you
so the question though is does it have
like a sphincter that big like it's like
a
like a airlock no because the problem
with having an anus that big is that
like your poop would just
fall out right like it would even stay
in your falls
all the time not the stink is big enough
it would come in handy if you wanted to
eat a lot of cheese
like you would never get constipated i
would think does cheese make you
constipated
once they come with me to get these uh
tanks we got to get all these tanks oh
my god
we have to get so many oh follow me all
the good kinds of tanks
wait jacob where are you oh you're dead
that's right absolutely
yes we're doing too much dilly dallying
ah you get her up i'm gonna go run away
and die alone
yeah i got you miss you jacob really
miss you you're so cute in your little
pink jacket
i know i know i bet she got the an anus
the size of like an orange maximum
yeah you're right we do we do get those
cans so you can get these cans
no no one no one came with me to get
this gas tank
no i'm going to get a separate gas tank
you can't shoot when you have the gas
tank i'm just slapping them
i didn't know that's a bit of a bummer
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god pipe on pipe bomb
go go go go go
all right oh somebody haven't did
somebody have a defibrillator
yeah i thought i did but i don't know
what happened oh wait i did
okay he's trying to
argue with me on facebook
is that it is that the last one
it is the last one goodbye legs
oh no oh look roll get it get it get it
get it
go go go go go go go go [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] dramatic this is not good
none of this is good i don't feel good
about any of this oh my god roll okay
did somebody have to help you i don't
know how we even get them we did it
though we did it
before i fall so what are you saying i
don't know how to get up there dangling
how did you get up there
why is this music why is this music
i mean i think it's because it's a horde
right
it's like the last horde
i don't know about that but it is a
horde coming up this ladder you're
getting [ __ ]
oh tank that's why that's why it's tank
it's a tank that's why the music
is
there we go okay okay okay okay
oh
[Applause]
okay that's good that's good that's good
oh i'm on fire oh none of it's good
oh gosh
okay okay
oh you incapacitated me because i'm all
tough i got the tank though i got the
tank what is that noise
why is this happening this is the escape
music
[ __ ] game oh man there's ammo down
here right where do we go
there's a flare or something in this guy
you see that there's a
on the boat okay sorry oh my god i need
more ammo so badly
but i can't i'm not gonna make this john
i'm so stuck
i can't move john
why did you leave me
everybody leave me alone oh my god oh my
god
i'm not gonna make it i'm not gonna make
it stupid
oh my gosh there you go it's all right
it still counts we still got through it